xi Jinping is the most powerful Chinese
president in decades he has many faces
tough guy she cracks down on corruption
statesmen she fights for free trade
national ashamed reclaims land in the
South China Sea and visionary she aims
to make China a great global power
here's how a boy who is sent to the
countryside to shovel sewage and feed
pigs reached the pinnacle of power she
was born in Beijing in 1953 his father
shi gyeong Joon was a communist
revolutionary leader and China's
propaganda chief who rose to become a
vice premier before being purged in Mao
Zedong's Cultural Revolution at the age
of 15 she too was affected by the
Cultural Revolution he was sent to a
rural village in northwestern China
where he lived in a cave house dug into
a hillside he was feeding pigs you know
he was like cleaning you know kind of
toilets he was doing farming you know in
his spare time he would read books
that's Bloomberg senior government
reporter kingship
I covered China's politics and foreign
relations while living in the
countryside he became a voracious reader
picking up everything from Victor Hugo
to Ernest Hemingway he took one of his
all-time favorite books with him
that is comics magnum opus Das Kapital
you've read it three times over seven
years in 1975 she was allowed to return
to Beijing where he studied chemical
engineering but his work as a communist
party member prevailed she rose to the
party ranks in the rapidly
industrialized coastal provinces of
Fujian and Jorge on his big break came
in 2007 with his promotion to top leader
of Shanghai the job aided she's
ascension to the party's all-powerful
Standing Committee setting him up to
succeed who Jintao as party leader
commander-in-chief and president by 2013
the transformation was complete she was
China's paramount leader
there was nothing obvious in early part
of his career to suggest he would become
one of China's most powerful leaders
ever having taken power she has
demonstrated his flair for hands-on
management and strict communist party
discipline he's launched a mouse style
campaign to tighten up controls on
ideology media and dissent by arresting
journalists and activists and he has
been overseeing probably the harshest
crackdown on activism and human rights
groups in the party's recent history in
addition she has pledged a blizzard of
economic reforms and ordered the biggest
military overhaul and since the 1950s he
had this great belief China totally
deserves to restore his place in the
world Chinese dream is the phrase he
coined to conveying this message while
she is seen as an able leader at home
he's only starting to establish China's
new power on the world stage and
President Donald Trump is accused XI of
failing to curb the nuclear ambitions of
North Korea so far he doesn't seem to be
able to give up on North Korea because
the fear about the collapse of North
Korea and the consequences of that but
she is the first Chinese president not
to visit North Korea and his argue China
isn't responsible for them and despite
their disagreements over North Korea and
trade she and US president Donald Trump
hit it off when he was in Malaga on his
first visit to the US he seems to be
totally in his element he was telling me
Trump about the history of the Korean
Peninsula and Trump's rolling out his
grandchildren to sing a Chinese song for
Xi Jinping just how long they're warm
rapport will last remains to be seen
back home she will complete his
consolidation of power with Party
Congress in Beijing in October 2017 when
roughly half of China's top officials
will be replaced the questions now are
will he use that power to force through
reforms needed to revamp the economy and
will China emerge to
the US as the world's number-one
superpower
[Music]
you